- I hear that there was dancing as well.
Like the dance scenes, right?
- Dance scenes, TikTok dances.
- 'Cause she's a TikTok star.
- Yes.
- So you're the one...
So how did dancing go?
- There was a lot of like
people rolling their backs
out in between when we had little breaks
because we were tired
and like out of shape
she had high expectations
of us, the dance instructor.
And so she-
- Maybe she saw your potential.
- Do you think?
- (laughs) Yes.
- Yeah. Maybe.
I mean, but it was so much fun.
It was like a bonding experience.
- I was at the lead of the pack.
- Yeah.
- Yeah? You were the dance captain?
(group laughing)
- Well, I always played a TikTok dancer
who's damned into the movie
because she has a lot of followers
but doesn't know how to act.
And she had to lead,
- Which is cool.
- them in these TikTok dances.
- Yeah, it was very scary.
I was constantly like shaking,
trying to do the dance moves, (laughs)
but it was really fun.
And I was told, like I had to
live up to Britney standards
which is not possible.
- Why did he even lay that on you?
- I don't know.
But we all had our different
like pop star alter egos.
I don't even think they
know that they had them,
but we, I mean, the dances-
- You would name them?
- They told me eventually.
- What was yours?
- I was Patti LaBelle.
(all laughing)
- Well, way to start at the top.
- Yeah, that's right.
That's what she told me.
She said "And Keegan,
you are Patti LaBelle."
(all giggling)
- Oh my God.
- I was like, oh, okay.
I will, so Patti LaBelle was
my spirit animal (mumbles)
- Spirit animal.
- Who's Maria?
- Yeah, what was yours?
- I never got one.
(all laugh)
- You didn't get one?
- No, you didn't get one, Maria.
- That's so sad.
- I know, yay!
- We're gonna think one by
the end of this episode,
I'm gonna have,
I feel like you had some
Channing Tatum skills,
probably you're really good.
- She's was great,
she did a really good job.
- Yeah.